dans les semaines qui ont suivi
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans
plusieurs centaines de réfugiés en
provenance de nombreuses provinces de
tout le pays se sont retrouvés ici dans
ce parc du centre de la capitale dans
l'espoir de pouvoir quitter le pays lors
de la prise de pouvoir des talibans ces
gens ont cherché à quitter leur pays par
tous les moyens beaucoup ont fait le
siège de l'aéroport de kaboul pendant
plusieurs jours espérant obtenir un vol
pour l'étranger un parc comme celui ci
était alors remplis de dizaines de
tentes et d'abris de fortune des
familles entières avaient quitté leur
maison leur village pour prendre
possession des lieux en attendant des
jours meilleurs
quand tous les réfugiés sont arrivés ici
ils ont occupé tout le terrain personne
pouvait jouer au football tout le
territoire était occupé par les réfugiés
ces deux parties cela fait un mois ou un
peu moins que tout le monde est parti et
on peut jouer au football tranquillement
faire du sport ils sont tous partis il
ya 15-20 jours qu'ils sont tous partis
ils sont revenus dans leur province et
maintenant on peut jouer au football et
le football
le nouveau gouvernement a finalement
proposé à toutes ces familles de rentrer
chez elles ont leur offrant une prime
afin de repartir du bon pied
avec l'aide de nombreuses organisations
ici à kaboul nous avons pu transférer
environ 4000 à 5000 familles afghanes de
divers endroits de la ville vers leur
famille grâce à un transport gratuit on
a payé encore 150 mille dollars
américains aux autres quinze mille
afghans fifty et stoller yes man is
actually raf et en distribuant cet
argent cette somme est réservé en cas
d'urgence pour 15 20 jours afin de leur
donner les moyens d'un retour à la vie
active au travail aux affaires
water works
une initiative qui a permis aux jeunes
du quartier de reprendre possession de
leur terrain de jeu préféré
[Musique]